a new story came out about the 25 most
dangerous jobs based on data from the
bureau Bureau of Labor Statistics
um
so I peeped these up
and the number five one was garbage
collectors
you don't think about it as being that
dangerous but you know that truck likes
to Chomp that truck will eat anything
that thing will eat a damn baby stroller
that [__] will eat an ex-wife if you
you know
if you you know did something wrong to
her you know uh so you know that thing
doesn't really have much of a conscience
on it
and it it also people throw a lot of you
know semi bad food out in the garbage
so I'm sure you cruising on the back of
that thing somebody threw a batch of bad
shrimp in there
and at first if you're like me if you're
in a car you see some food or something
you're like I'm not gonna have any but
for some reason three minutes later I'm
eating it
doesn't matter what it's like that
gardetto's or whatever that [__] I hate
it you put it back by me I look at it I
say I hate that
three minutes later I'm eating it I'm
eating these little [__] toasts made
for damn elves or whatever I'm eating
I'm making a little [__] sandwiches
putting a little peanut between I'm
eating it
so I can imagine it's the same thing
when you're out back there you you know
you're hiding on the back of that g
truck they always got two freaking uh
little recycle bunnies hanging off the
back of that [__]
and
and you forget somebody you know talk
you know somebody threw in some bad
shrimp you out there a mile later you
[__] have two of them
next thing you know you you six feet
under the sea baby that's it bad shrimp
take anybody out a king or a pauper
so I could really see how that is uh the
number five job
that is um unhealthy for people
the number four most toughest uh most
dangerous job roofers it says right here
roofers
um you know them little lid monkeys baby
if you if that's if you want to put a
top on something they're trying to
they're trying to shut everything down
and close everything in if you're a
roofer uh I remember we used to invite
this one kid over to play uh to play at
the house
and me and my buddy we would call him
and invite him to live across the street
but then we'd get up on the roof with a
couple pellet guns and
um just spice them up spice his skin up
when he walked over
and he he already had this little fella
had some uh he wasn't a little bit he
was
he has some bone density deal going on
and uh
so pardon was little and partum was big
you know he was just kind of that little
um that little wobble rabbit you know
that little shake it like a song [__]
you know he just had that built into him
and uh and we're still all friends and
[__] it was just childhood [__] but if
we didn't have a roof that kind of [__]
don't happen
so I'm not shocked that Roofing gets
real real dangerous overall
number three we have uh Derek operators
in oil and gas mining
and that doesn't surprise me That's
dangerous because
I mean natural gas that's basically
mother that's Mother Nature has got a
it's just a fart that's hiding inside of
Mother Nature
that's all it is man natural gas all
that is man
so you're telling me say you're laying
somewhere right and some dude rolls up
with a needle and sticks it in your body
and tries to suck a damn
butt puff right out of you bro
dude I'll beat the elbows off that dude
he won't be able to hug anybody he won't
be able to hug correctly for damn 18
months
so that's all Mother Nature look that's
danger if you're trying to just you know
suck a big dirt puff right out of Mother
Nature's abdomen then you get you get
sideswiped by her or whatever
I'm not surprised she's beating people's
asses and and really causing hell and
causing fatal accidents as fatal
accidents
so they don't shock you man any creep
trying to suck something out of Mother
Nature's gut is a real freak I think
they are real booty freak nature Style
this is uh I can't tell if it's getting
bored of me or not but number two uh
aircraft pilots and it says private
helicopter and aircraft Pilots
and I think the the issue with them why
it could be dangerous because there's
not as much with commercial pilots
there's more
checks and balances there's other Pilots
that they are all going to the airport
with and
but private you just call your guy hey
I'm ready to go you know we're leaving
in eight hour leaving in three hours you
know and he could be doing anything he
could be hopped up on a couple blue
shoes half an eight ball whatever
so now next thing you know he's up there
he's navigating you know the rich then
that's the rich man
if you get rich it gets risky
you know there's a cost to beat a boss
and
and so that's what I think they get they
get these Pilots that they're ready to
go but they could have been up to no
good right before
so you get some dude up there he's still
all you know geeked up
on some of that [__] uh on some of
that nose broth baby you know what I'm
saying liquid cocaine
and
he's he's on damn hinge up there he's
swiping on matches
and the next thing you know he just
swipes your [__] Lear jet into the
side of a mountain
so I think that that's the issue with
that I would imagine
and the last one here is logging workers
login workers I mean you just get a real
a lot of a lot of people that are trying
to stay off the grid
a lot of people
um and it's not really the tree you got
to worry about that much
because a tree only has two moves it has
one it has the fall
and then the real most dangerous move of
a tree the role
people don't think about that [__]
people yell timber and it falls then it
[__] rolls over nine people
because they don't have a nobody thought
of another thing for after timber that's
really just ignorance
so you get that Timber but you don't get
that double up on the roll people
getting damn rolled out you know all of
a sudden you know [__] step dance
flat and y'all poor
so it's just
you know they don't have a good plan for
that I think with logging and the
secondary issue is this man a lot of CR
a lot of just
crawdad humans out there I work with
this dude Ronnie bro
and they call them big hat Ronnie and he
was a brother and he had mental
retardation
and me and him got hired and um
I was supposed to be the boss but he
didn't understand what that meant so
you know when he was bigger than me
anyway and so we were both [__] we're
about you know we're out there doing
work for my buddy Richard who actually
died but
we're out there and Heat this dude bro
once they lit that saw up they gave him
that [__] he [__] cut everything bro
this dude cut [__] bird feeders in
half cutting [__] fences open didn't
give a [__] he cut open a damn chain
link fence bruh
this dude man we he probably hit four
trees in about maybe half an afternoon
that's due to cut a new [__] bathroom
into your [__] kitchen this dude
didn't give a [__] bro
so and he loved the uh Lakers he loved
the Lakers I remember that
and I hope he's doing well too
and he'd walk to work that dude leave
for work at 4 30 and get to work at
[__] seven bro
and do walk to work
just greased out natural God's grease
baby sweat
and he just like wants that [__] gas
fumes hit him in that [__] little
baby that little just that spinning
scissor sword bro he [__] cut
anything
[__] cut the damn Earth open dude he
didn't give a [__] bruh
so I can see how logging is dangerous
because the trees and then the people
you're doing it with they're [__]
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one